baby sitting k rime avec Speed Dating je
vous le disais voici les
explications bonsoir à nos deux
nouvelles invitéses Isabelle Ramin et
Catherine Bastoni bonsoir à toutes les
deux adjointe à la jeunesse et à la
petite enfance respectivement donc sur
la ville de Montini le Bretonneux la
ville qui lance son Bab cting Bab site
dating pas évident à dire mais une fois
qu'on a pris le coup ça va plus vite
hein ce sera samedi 26 janvier en mairie
les parents vont rencontrer des
étudiants des lycéens de 16 ans au
minimum et pourquoi pas les embaucher
comment cela va fonctionner comme un
speed deting justement oui alors tout à
fait donc ça va fonctionner comme un
speed dating l'idée c'est de permettre
aux familles de rencontrer des jeunes à
la recherche d'un de babys sitting et
donc ce seront les les familles qui
auront qui réservent des créneaux d'une
heure pour pouvoir rencontrer des des
jeunes voilà Bab site dating est-ce que
c'est suffisant pour faire garder son
enfant quelques minutes pour convaincre
ces jeunes qui vont être présents ah
c'est rassurant pour les parents malgré
tout mais écoutez je crois qu'on est
tous en tant que parents on a tous fait
appel en tout cas à des babysiters pour
une soirée au cinéma ou au théâtre pour
dépané pour une sortie d'école ou autre
oui ça fait partie quand même du bien
vivre ensemble sur Montini pourquoi vous
avez mis en place un tel dispositif
justement c'était une demande
véritablement aussi la population ou
cétait c'était un besoin des familles et
puis également une attente des jeunes
donc j'ajouterai à votre questionnement
sur quelles sont les aptitudes des
jeunes que le pôle jeunesse a déjà
organisé des ateliers d'information pour
les jeunes donc nous avons déjà 25
jeunes qui ont participé à des ateliers
leur permettant et bien de voir un petit
peu le fonctionnement avec l'appui d'un
sapeur pompier et euh d'assistante
maternelle donc je dirais en plus que de
ce qu'a dit ma collègue que c'est
vraiment un travail de partenariat entre
le secteur fam famille enfance petite
enfance mais également le scolaire et le
le Pô de jeunesse donc là c'est la
première fois que ce rendez-vous est
lancé c'est la première fois que ce
rendez-vous on invite expressément les
inimontins et les jeunes parce que les
jeunes c'est toujours un petit peu un
public un peu plus difficile à capter
donc et bien samedi en mairie à venir se
rencont on a dit 14h 14 et ce jusqu'à
18h il y a une quarantaine de parents
déjà qui sont inscrits en revanche y a
une vingtaine de jeunes si j'ai bien su
presque 25 ça a progressé de 5 depuis le
début d'après-midi ça sera pas suffisant
ça veut dire qu'il faut vraiment
mobiliser les jeunes oui mais les jeunes
au-delà de ça vont à eux vont être en
permanence de 14h à 18h jusqu'à
rencontrer la famille qui voudra bien
deux et cette échange se fera et puis on
désespère pas que notre passage à TVfil
que N qui nous suivent de venir
s'inscrire en les parents les les poues
justement pour aller faire un petit peu
d'argent de poche forcément c'est
toujours bénéfique on va juste faire une
pause on va se rendre dans les les ru de
CS en nivel nous sommes allés rencontrer
quelques familles pour leur demander si
elle rencontrait des difficultés pour
faire garder leurs enfants justement au
micro trottoir d'é diine papi mamie
voilà c'est la bonne route de
secours ou entre amis aussi entre amis
c'est vrai que on se rend service
mutuellement pas du tout en fait mon
épouse a choisi de d'éduquer notre fils
d'accord donc elle a mis en parenthèse
sa vie professionnelle des babysit on a
un budget babysitter qui explose voilà
tous les vendredis soir et samedi soir
c'est babite non on s'organise on arrive
un peu à entre les grands et les petits
à se à se les grands gardent un peu les
petits de temps en temps fait appel à
des babysitter quand nos grands eux vont
garder d'autres enfants et ben on prend
des babysitter pour garder les nôtres
non parce que j'ai la chance d'être à la
maison donc j'ai pas ce problème là
quand on sort avec ma femme et que on s
une petite sortie entre nous sans les
enfant donc on les fait garder il a un
système de débrouille aussi d' TR on
entend des papi mamie par exemple c'est
devenu un vrai budget hein véritablement
pour les familles de trouver aussi des
des babiciteurs ces famillesl vous allez
ensuite les suivre les jeunes aussi vont
être suivis un suivi de la mairie qui
sera effectué c'est vraiment c'est juste
de la mise en c'est de la mise en
relation c'est vraiment je dirais une
nouvelle édition et et une version un
petit peu plus moderne d'un service qui
existait déjà en mairie et qui était
porté par le Pôle Jeunesse puisqu'il y
avait un un fichier permettant de de de
dresser la liste des jeunes qui étaient
en recherche de de babysitting et qui
était ouvert aux parents voilà donc là
bien j'invite tous les parents et tous
les jeunes à aller sur le site de la m
sur le mode de fonctionnement on va
peut-être rappeler comment ça fonctionne
il faut s'inscrire tout de même
auparavant famille comme jeune voilà
donc effectivement de s'inscrire sur le
site de la mairie et là ils seront pris
en charge et il y aura donc un un rappel
téléphonique des service du pôle
jeunesse pour leur expliquer les les
modalités tant pour les familles que
pour que pour les les jeunes et puis si
jamais ils n'ont pas eu le temps de
s'inscrire qui n'hésite pas malgré tout
à venir aussi en mairie samedi prochain
de 14h à 18h les différents informations
différentes informations qui se sont
affichées bien évidemment on disait
premier rendez-vous est-ce que si on
ratait le coach par exemple pour les
parents comme pour les jeunes vous allez
organiser des sessions de rattrapage
sera encore possible de se mettre en
relation après ou pourquoi pas le bilan
se fera l'issue de cette première
édition et puis nous verrons et pourquoi
pas élargir on y a songé
intergénérationnellement
qui
sou en complément des jeunes
également commun comme versaill par
exemple qui ont déjà lancé ce ce genre
de rendez-vous vous en êtes inspiré ou
vous avez regardé un peu ce qui s'était
passé aux alentours oui bien sûr on a
regardé effectivement ce qui se passait
aux alentours et effectivement il y a eu
déjà trois éditions du même type de de
format sur sur Versailles on vous
souhaite le même succès forcément voilà
merci beaucoup à toutes les deux date de
ce rendez-vous 26 janvier dimanche en
mairie à suivre le rendez-vous
environnement avec Valérie oribo avant
de vous rendre au babyitting de Montini
dimanche vous pourrez aussi découvrir
l'expo père et fils c'est en maie de
Guille en cours actuellement à la
commune qui est juste à côté de Montini
c'est une opération réalisée dans le
cadre du cycle des pères proposé par la
ville des hommes au tors nu côte à côte
bras dessus dessous un père et son fils
parfois ce sont même trois générations
que le photographe Grégoire korganov
immortalise sur ses clichés j'habite
guillancour et on regarde pas mal les
activités de l'école des parents il y a
un an on avait participé déjà pour les
10 ans de l'école à une séance photo
avec une photographe et là on nous a
proposé de de faire partie aussi de de
ce groupe autour de ce stème perfice
donc ça m'a bien bien intéressé et il se
trouve que mon père était dans le coin à
ce moment-l et que c'était l'occasion de
faire une séance photo familiale et de
bons souvenirs AG guancour c'est toute
la famille de Marc qui a décidé de
prendre la pause devant l'objectif du
photographe c'est un photographe
professionnel donc il a pas combien il a
fait une centaine de photos une centaine
de pris de vue ce qui fait que il faut
il faut se détendre il faut l'écouter il
faut voà il faut se bien supplier au
entre guillemets aux règles qu'il
demande quoi déjà la relation pèrefils
Petitfils et cetera puis de de partager
un moment comme ça où on est obligé de
de faire des gestes je dirais un peu de
de de tendresse de de remémorer les
choses de se
regarder l'idée est née il y a
maintenant presque 3 ans
euh c'est mon petit
garçon qui que nous avons adopté sa mère
et moi et donc qui est la peau noire il
est né au Randa
et qui un jour en rentrant de
l'école le soir enfin le soir au moment
du dîner nous dit voilà je comprends pas
papa maman on dit que je suis pas votre
fils parce que vous avez la peau blanche
et moi j'ai la peau
noire le photographe s'interroge alors
sur la ressemblance l'affiliation le
rôle du père de la mère et de l'enfant
et puis je dis à Marco mon fils je
écoute je vais faire plein de photos de
papa avec leur filles si tu vas voir il
y en a qui se ressembleront et puis il y
en a qui ne se ressembleront pas et
voilà c'est parti comme ça si Grégoire
korganov a déjà photographié plus de 150
personnes à Guill encour c'est une
quinzaine de paires qu'il a rencontré
pour réaliser 23 portraits ces clichés
sont à découvrir à l'hôtel de ville de
guyancour jusqu'au 16
février et puis petite rectification par
rapport au plateau précédent le
rendez-vous babyite à Montini le
Bretonneux à partir de 14h ce sera le
samedi 26 janvier et non le dimanche
dimanche 27 donc samedi 26 janvier à
partir de 14h en mairie de Montini le
Bretonneux